just want to bring you some breaking
news coming into us via NBC and they are
saying that President Biden is preparing
to make his intention excuse me to seek
a second term official next week Biden
advisors are planning to launch his
re-election campaign as soon as next
Tuesday that's according to three
sources that have spoken to NBC and uh
Biden advisors have said for months that
no formal timetable have been settled on
for Mr Biden to launch his re-election
campaign but they have long been looking
at April the 25th which is the
anniversary of uh President Biden's 2020
campaign announcement and then that was
an informal Target that they were
looking at
um so that then the breaking news that
President Biden is preparing to make his
intention to seek a second term official
next week the pictures that you're
seeing of his uh recent visit
to Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland